maybe it's human nature to want to
combine two things together to make one
thing then some of those combinations
everybody knows about but others are
created out of a desire to experiment
imagination helps us to combine things
that will never ever exist like the
amazing king of rudl sometimes things
come together and the most wonderful and
unexpected piece but they don't always
work out as you planned so I see you
studied chemistry and theater in school
how do you think that's gonna help you
move cars off this Lots little quirks of
how we combine things make us who we are
you put coffee in your teeth yeah I know
it's kind of weird right I did the same
thing I'm Ryan
Natalie and most of the time never
really know what's going to happen right
there I think it looks like a pool I
think it looks like a kangaroo
if you think about it everything that's
important starts with how you take two
things and put them together what are
you you're right
I think he does have your nose but he is
your eyes and those two things can
create the greatest combination of all
what are your favorite two-in-one
combinations